you know i bring up tick tock videos
somewhat frequent
only the ones that kind of go viral and
make make their way around the internet
i'm not on tick tock myself
i i feel that xi jinping has enough of
my information but i i do catch it on
twitter or youtube sometimes
so there was a video of a young person
describing the difference between i want
to get this right
between aromanticism
and asexuality these are now two sexual
identities and and so one
is aromantic you're not roman and the
other is asexual here's the difference
this is a reminder that non-asexual
aromantic
and allosexual aromantic are not always
interchangeable
non-asexual aromantic includes
identities such as my own
i'm not asexual but i'm not allosexual
either
my experiences are going to be very
different from an allosexual aromantic
person's
i think it's just important if you're an
ally who's talking about aromantic
issues
if you're talking about allosexual
aromantic issues
make sure to say allosexual aromantic
there's nothing wrong with that term
just saying
non-asexual aromantic also includes
other aromantic people who might
not experience sexual attraction but
still don't identify as asexual
just something to keep in mind that is
something that if you keep it in your
mind
your mind will turn to soup i don't
i want to be pretty clear by the way i
am not
poking fun at this confused young
person's idea of sexuality
i am actually indignant and
outraged by the way that our culture has
warped this young person's mind and
confused
this young person i'm not not exactly
clear i don't want to be
wrong about identities and the aloe and
the amo and the whatever
this the identities are so i googled it
i googled the aromantic and
i don't know what aloe is but arrow i
saw is
a aromantic that's the lingo for
aromantic and it means you're not
romantically attracted to people but you
do enjoy having sex with them sometimes
possibly
and then asexual is you don't enjoy
having sex with people
but you may be romantically attracted to
them
how does that work i don't no nobody
knows nobody nobody knows but this these
are just
two of the newer sexual identities there
will probably be a half dozen more by
the time we finish this show today and
there aren't that
many more minutes left in the show but
there will still be more of these things
because getting back to the point
on uh race that the girl scouts brought
up
you know that racial blindness
colorblindness
is actually awful because it erases
people's identity
if your identity as a culture
is in the font of being you know i am
that i am god
is another name for him uh then you you
will know who you are
and you will have a fixed point that you
are
moving toward and that that you are uh
identifying yourself with if you do not
you will be as my
friend father george rutler has pointed
out if you do not i find your identity
in the i am who i
am you will find your identity with this
v or you will attempt to find your
identity with a pathetic question which
is who am i
you'll say i'm an elo a row [ __ ] a sex
trans bi none whatever and you'll it
will never end it will never end because
you are not sufficient because you are a
contingent being
who is imperfect because this is a
fallen world
and you will never be satisfied with
your own identity we'll just go on and
on and on
hey hold up there you idiots
i know you're you're idiots according to
the liberal establishment you're
obviously much more intelligent than
they are it goes without saying
but you know what would make you an
idiot if you didn't subscribe and like
and ring the bell uh there's a whole
episode here you can go check that out
called the idiot percentage you get on
the michael knowles show on apple
podcast spotify google play all of these
other things
and uh i hope to see you next time
especially if you've read my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we can bask in our own deplorable
irredeemable bitter
clinging bible thumping idiocy together
see you next time